it's a test model of the car of Tomorrow
a car that drives itself everybody would
like to know why self-driving is taking
so long including the people that are
developing it themselves
and
um you know Troy answers nobody really
knows otherwise they would be just
fixing that problem
[Music]
years ago Google kicked off a digital
Gold Rush when it had announced that it
had developed a self-driving car the
Google driverless car led to a spin-off
called waymo spurred tens of billions of
dollars in investment by companies like
GM Apple Tesla and Uber and sent
futurists fantasizing about a world
without steering wheels driver's
licenses or traffic fatalities and at
the center of all this was this man my
name is Anthony Lewandowski I'm the CEO
of pronto and Paulin Pronto is an
autonomous technology company and pollen
is building the Next Generation mobile
network we build technology for making
vehicles that drive themselves starting
with the off-road market and so we do
quarries and mines and places that are
not accessible to the public
ever since I've been a little kid I've
loved playing with Legos and through
college that naturally grew into
robotics I loved you know building these
vehicles to drive on their own there's
something really magical about them
lewandowski's early career started when
he created and sold pre-bod a modified
Toyota Prius which you sold to Google
after departing Google he worked for
Uber's driverless car division this
switch caused controversy Google sued
Uber and the government charged him with
Trade Secrets theft he pled guilty but
he was pardoned on the last day of the
Trump presidency now he's back but with
a decidedly scaled down vision for
self-driving cars
we were starting Pronto our first
product is autonomous College which is
the trucks that move material to mine
from the pits to the crossing plants our
next product is driver assist systems
for semi trucks where we're not there to
replace the driver but we're there to
make their lives easier and safer so one
of the main things we wanted to do was
understanding how well we could drive
long distances on the highway when we
did the actual attempts it took us four
tries that's amazing but it's also like
really bad because if you died three
times out of four times you were trying
to drive across the country that's
clearly not sufficient enough to do over
that person but one of the things I
would say there that was interesting is
on every single one of our attempts we
saw at least one semi truck rolled over
on the side of the road so it kind of
reinforced the need for the assistive
technology right so these are probably
individuals that were really tired and
the technology that we're making we
think is going to be able to greatly
alleviate those kinds of accents what
we're here today is the Mark West Quarry
it's one of the sites where we've
deployed our Pronto autonomous
technology doing autonomous Hollis
autonomous haulage that basically means
the robot mining trucks that go from the
pits or the materials being extracted to
the processing plant and repeat all day
long we have our system installed on two
trucks at the location here where the
trucks are driving completely
autonomously with nobody inside them and
nobody remote controlling them and
that's very different from an assistive
technology to help the truck driver on
the trucks operating at the Quarry here
we have a set of cameras GPS radios that
together help the truck see what's
around the vehicle the operator presses
the button the truck then backs up and
goes to the hopper and dumps the
material Into The Crusher and then it
comes back and re-does that operation
all day long this is kind of like a
double black diamond you know Quarry in
terms of like the tightness for it and
like how steep the inclines are and you
only have one lane for the hall humans
are driving this route before right I
mean this is correct yeah yeah they were
doing a little bit differently right
they don't have to turn around here and
they'd have to do a little you know
Austin Powers move at the top to turn
around so we can do faster Cycles by
going forward and backwards what's the
hardest part of this I mean just from a
technological standpoint getting it to
be reliable yeah right so you can always
do something and then it's like cool it
worked once but then when you try to
make it work you know ten thousand out
of ten thousand times there's always new
things that you didn't expect where's
Google and GM's crews are still focused
on building so-called Robo taxis that is
vehicles that operate without any
oversight Lewandowski says that true
self-driving cars are still years if not
decades away so he's focused on
applications in the Here and Now
Lewandowski still believes that
self-driving cars and that wonderful
world he once promised will come he's
just not sure when and he doesn't think
anyone knows self-driving is defined as
the occupant is now responsible for the
movement of the vehicle and therefore
they could be without a driver's license
and not knowing how to drive the vehicle
I'm a firm believer in that I believe
they will happen I think it's gonna be
transformational it's a trillion dollar
you know a year business uh that
everybody's chasing the gold standard is
going to be a car that can pick anything
up anywhere to touch a button on your
phone the technology has gotten a lot
better but it hasn't improved far enough
to be able to do what we all wanted to
do in terms of looking at why we were
having all the problems we were having
in the future of what's happening around
you in the road is really the the part
that the computers aren't good at I see
that the only metric that determines
when an autonomous vehicle is ready is
safety it doesn't matter how much it
costs it doesn't matter how bulky they
are how ugly they are the the only
metric is defined is safety like are
they safer than a person
[Music]
laughs